I think that all young people graduating
from say high school certainly need to
understand the basic elements of
mathematics certainly through algebra
hopefully a bit beyond that understand
to some extent how it can be used to
model the real world they need to
understand and this is a critical issue
today they need to understand what
science is that it is a way of drawing
on hundreds of years of human
intelligence being applied to measuring
things to understanding what objective
data are and to take facts and put them
together and build them into theories
into understanding of how things work
and then how that can be taken through
the field of engineering to designing
and building things that extend their
capabilities and enable us to do our
jobs so they need to be able to
quantitatively reason they need to
understand what science is and what the
scientific method is they need to
understand that without without that
scientific and mathematical underpinning
you cannot build big structures you
cannot run industries you cannot have
your health improve it's really those
basics that I think our young people
need to know because believe me if you
go to China and Singapore and parts of
India and so forth you'll find a lot of
kids going very quickly fire in the
belly in these fields and ultimately
wanting to eat our lunch we can't let
them do that we have to both compete and
cooperate but our young people need to
have the opportunities that the new age
is going to provide them
you